guys eSports in 2018 really pulled on
our heartstrings we saw underdog stories
heroic comebacks and moments that
transcended the eSports scene they took
place in there were plenty of times that
reminded us just how heartwarming the
eSports community at large can be so in
honor of those moments let us take you
on a journey we're calling the top 10
I'm not crying you're crying moments of
2018 the holidays are a time for
families to be together
which is why Street Fighter 5 player
Sacco and his adorable daughter kick off
our list of heartwarming moments
transcends all of the toxicity in chat
showing just how wholesome the fgc could
be Sacco brought both his wife and his
daughter to August Taiwan fighter major
and after he secured a devastating 3o
victory over taquito his daughter rushed
to the stage to congratulate her old man
in what may very well be one of 2018 s
cutest moments this is actually the
eyecup you got me ready to go home and
be a family man right not somebody
where's that for cosplay Obama right now
marry me right now it's the only way
we're gonna have a family the power of
love transcends at all the beautiful
daughter a Socko and a Kiki Sokka was
able to beat the top tier on mother
coumadin Ito not beat 3 always rain and
the wife she's crying the tears are
holding the tears and the daughter held
by Mago and the kis room choujuu Hakeem
saying I'm next now the pressures on me
of course he's a newlywed coming in at
number nine is score winning his first
domestic title score started his league
of legends career in 2012 but a domestic
title has always seemed to escape him
despite being considered one of the
world's best players after coming so
close so many times
Katie's victory over Griffin in the 2018
LC case on the finals not only gave the
team momentum heading into the league of
Legends World Championship but finally
gave score a championship to call his
own definitely very instrumental to the
win today their support was phenomenal
and I really wanted us to win I'm really
sad that I couldn't give this win to my
past teammates Katie teammates I wish
they were here as well and my ultimate
goal every season was to let my team win
and I'm really happy that today's the
day taking the number 8 spot on our list
is one of the most unlikely major runs
of all time 16 to 14 and gentlemen
complex is taking down phonetic on
Inferno for the first game here the
legend stage that is shocking with a
roster made up of underdog players and
veterans Ernie men complexity managed to
make their mark on the London major and
bring down the likes of legend we need
to go to a yay camp right now
is jacked up ng to shock took three HP
and a one versus four with fifteen
seconds not this time 16 to 11
complexity with the upset has to be said
over g2 on route to the bracket stage
this bomb plant isn't even gonna go down
and yeas done it who better to close it
out now let's put the attention on def
because that UK player first one into
the legend stage and he had so many
important rounds down the stretch of
this game and it still seems like they
just say can't even believe it
themselves and while they didn't manage
to go any further finishing in the top
eight while securing a spot at the next
major is enough to warm even the most
jaded na fans heart mostly the best
yellow romantic movies because after all
who doesn't like a good old underdog
story
emotionally
thanks for bringing the baptized
really appreciate you guys bring the
shine back on this division we're
dedicating the number seven spot on this
list to Invictus gaming rookie and his
emotional reaction to a G's unexpected
win at the league of legends 2018 World
Championships rookie letting it all out
he is the one who committed to the
exchange going to the LPL five years
invested now it's all worth it
IG were not the favorites going into
Worlds 2018 but after China's Royal
never give up were knocked out of the
tournament
coupled with there not being a single
Korean team in the semi-finals IG seized
on a golden 2018 world champions while
huge for the region you got more out of
a G's win than mid laner rookie who left
Korea four years ago and worked his tail
off to become not only one of the
region's best mid laners but a world
champion the dream of every competitive
league of Legends team now being
realized as Invictus gaming will hoist
the summoner's top together
and claim their victory without the
world local crowd behind him so soon
Akagi
who's my tomato hollandaise to cut
really was about the hustle Robin they
counted them all to another cool oh sure
[Applause]
sure it's report your entire life
towards this moment well see later guys
you know just I just fold up Elsa it's
just a little fancy there overcome with
emotion but support 13 year walking
later so she's a tow yard either so
she's a sound fancier it was easy to put
on some offense to the house take a walk
all here kokujin some senators a logical
ways to go with who feels young as a
festival season
speaking in Chinese so hoping will will
hold off for us but of course it's true
right how much he's committed to the LPL
as well saying these coming in at number
six is n A's hero skadoodle and more
specifically his reaction to becoming
one of North America's first ever csgo
major champions at the Boston major
skadoodle is a veteran of the NA scene
and his incredible performance at the
major was a surprise to many who thought
they'd already seen him few years ago
[Applause]
maybe you wouldn't be able to perform
but you proved them wrong skedaddle
what do you have
you know I came out to play you know I
don't really it was the finals and no
regrets skadoodle retired from the
competitive landscape later in the year
but his legacy as the NA star who
brought a championship to the region is
set in stone
first I want to give a shout out to you
know my friends personally who came out
to support me
Tarek's fighting came out as well our
CEO came to see us win which is really
really nice and thank you for all the
fans who showed up I can't really say
too much I'm just super part of the boys
and as a first major playoff appearance
it's uh it's amazing sorry
I don't do this for the money I'm gonna
be donating of at least 10k from the
wings to me why few things warm the
heart more than seeing a tournament
winner give a gift to their opponent
which is why sonic Fox's generosity at
the injustice - Pro Series finals comes
in at number five on our list
[Music]
if you're interested
immediately after defeating rewind in
the tournament's Grand Finals
sonic Fox announced that he would be
donating $10,000 of his winnings to
rewind to help with his father's cancer
treatments if you pay attention to
rewind Twitter they'll know that his dad
actually has cancer I'm pretty sure and
he just recently got a surgery so right
away I don't do this for the money I'm
gonna be donating up at least ten cakes
and the wings to rewind so that it can
help out with his father's pains but
he's a little bit one of my good friends
when my training partners and so very
happy to have Sheriff David though if
that's not the epitome of the holiday
spirit and I don't know what is three
times for target champion
justice to champion how can you got this
hit oh geez championship run at t i8
finds its way at number four on our list
all thanks to no tail and the
unbreakable power of friendship and
determination as real as well Oh G lost
two of their star players heading into
the International 2018 and after a
last-minute rebuild saw them field an
unexpected lineup they managed to win it
all on DotA's biggest stage
[Applause]
friendship
[Applause]
champions
she team captain no-tell had entered
many TI's as a tournament favorite but
this year his team was perceived to be
one of the tournament's weakest but og
is a team built on friendship and Trust
which only makes the fact that they beat
the likes of people geniuses
Martha and LGD twice
[Applause]
of his lifetime three dead now on LGD
mob buy back all the more heartwarming
for one of the scenes most whistled
veterans it's real breathe in take your
time
hundreds of thousands of people here
a few surplus
[Applause]
[Applause]
few overwatch players are more beloved
than the Big Boss himself which is why
Pines inspiring story comes in at number
three when pine vanished from the public
eye in March his fans were worried about
him
and as it turned out their worry was
warranted as pine was going through a
power walk after his team won the
second-stage playoffs without him the
beloved New York Excelsior player
revealed that he was dealing with
depression and suffered from panic
attacks that drained him of his
competitive drive Kobe is harvesting
[Music]
don't bleed Oh honeycomb autumn sanity
my own flesh you own there are you came
with a head and I was get all but pine
bounced back and the honesty in which he
talked about his struggles and his
desire to improve not only made him more
endearing to his fans but further
solidified his place as one of eSports
best role models Sports is still a young
form of competition which among other
things means that many of our game's
biggest stars are young as well few
legends have truly retired and almost
none have died but for the few that have
passed on the community always finds a
way to honor their legacy and to
announce the winner of our first ever
Dennis Pavelka award it will be one of
his championship teammates from team
envyus the always smiling at Mickey the
emotional core of the Dallas fuel
congratulations Becky dennis internet
Hulka velka was beloved amongst the
overwatch community he touched many
players and fans lives over the course
of his career and after his death
Blizzard chose to memorialize him with
an award the reason why I'm here because
of him pick me up from the World Cup
first year like it would be like very
very hard for the sea people to like
join the tournament in u.s. like
especially joy to an a team so this was
like for me I'm very glad about it I
mean I don't want to feel I don't want
to be emotional in front of the camera
of course so yeah basically like every
happy like to get this warrant and this
is remind me a lot of memories the
Dennis have Velka award to recognize
players who like Pavelka have made a
positive impact on the community most
people know that Mickey I was always
wearing a smile it's actually true just
I've really never seen Mickey truly
upset I mean sometimes he gets serious
because he has to but outside of that
Vicky is Mickey if he is what you see
and what you expect make you thank you
for being such a shining example of
positivity and kindness
I know Dennis would be very very proud
she's one of these teammates to receive
this award
beloved ootah to cast receivers story at
T ia is one of the most heartwarming
things that eSports saw all year I can't
thank you enough for opening up yourself
and your family and sharing your story
with everyone Cheever who was diagnosed
with cancer last year detailed her story
at ti in an emotional segment that
touched the hearts of dota 2 fans across
the globe yeah that was it was a tough
one to take everything just changes in
an instant
yeah it's just just just like that
the video touched on how she along with
her friends family and the dota 2
community at large reacted to her
diagnosis and detailed her inspiring
road to recovery I remember my brother
coming into the door and I don't know I
just broke because yeah
it was just a friendly face at a time
where I didn't really have any like I
didn't feel like I had anything to look
forward to her story was so powerful
that it brought herself and the entire
dota 2 community to tears you know I
don't notice I don't notice that the
whole situation anymore obviously my
hair sucks I'm more chubby than what I
used to be that's so fine but the hot
flashes they just remind me every hour
and I'm not else
and I know that this was a little over a
year ago that you were diagnosed can you
give us an update on where your health
is today right now but the hot flesh is
still suck other than that in December
I'm on the waiting list
and in December I hope to be getting my
second boot be a good one and then I'm
on hormone therapy which is basically a
pill every day and a job every month
that removes any estrogen for my body so
that will go on for another four years
and after that it is basically rolled a
bite see if he comes back or not and
hope that it doesn't and that the odds
are in my favor so that's at least
something but I think I speak for most
dota 2 fans when I say Casey put it best
[Applause]
well guys that was our list now look as
the new year starts let's all remember
what's actually important the things
that bring us together not the things
that separate us so whether you're a
counter-strike fan you love League of
Legends or you're obsessed with
overwatch remember we're all in this
together thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]